Jordan are you checking me live yes
excellent thank you okay good evening
members and officers welcome to watch
for District Council's remotes executive
meeting and welcome to anyone watching
this via livestream I'm chairing this
evening's meeting in my capacity as
deputy leader as a result of councillor
Steptoe stepping down as leader item one
please apologies for absence there are
none item two non members attending
plays Sonya we have counselors mrs.
Gooding this is sure and you are new
thank you very much
Madson three minutes of the meeting held
on the 17th of June are you happy that
these are a true record yes a grade
grade just everybody great great
Thank You members gender item four to
receive declarations of interest are
there any of these evening members no
thank you very much gender item five
questions on notice from counselors
there are none and agenda item six
matters referred to the executive
executive and reports from other
committees there are none item 7 Council
it's program management office Angela
would you like to come in there please
thank you madam chairman
the report members is to to note this
evening this is the quarterly report of
the program management office as report
states the PMO is currently looking
after or seized of three projects and
two of those are reported within this
document and the third the connect
program is the subject of the report you
will hear later on in this agenda the
first project is the ICT migration
projects and as it says in the report
subject to two software programs and
some finalization of the 365 migration
this project is virtually complete it
remains only open because of the
interdependency around the physical
server and so I would expect when we
bring this report back to the next
quarter that there'll be a closing out
report for this project it will be
complete I will be working with the
Assistant Director for transformation
and customer to prepare a closeout
report for that projects and that will
include a review of lessons learned and
the sorts of things that you might
expect asked as a PMO to look at in
terms of closing out a project in
relation to beagle Duty Cova dar plans
unfortunately from May of this year were
disrupted but I'm pleased to say that
with the relaxation of restrictions
construction works are happening now at
RSPB Wallace the island the observation
platform has been completed the Beagle
Markway markers for the for the trail
are currently being put in place and the
improvement works to the car park are
also under construction the cgi that we
have the national lottery heritage
funding for is nearing completion also
and I expect that to that part of the
project to close out within the next six
weeks or so and that coincides then with
creation
of interpretation boards which will be
cited at policy island in time for the
summer holidays and we'll be looking to
promote those once those are up and
running you'll remember members that we
asked schoolchildren to contribute to a
competition for a poster for the event
and the winning class from King Evans
school unfortunately were on a duty
covered or have been unable to take up
the prize of a day at RSPB as part of
the opening event so we'll be liaising
with the school in September once
everybody's back and hopefully things
have reached a new normal with a view to
making sure that those children don't
miss out on the opportunity that we
already gave them and that their
contributions for the poster competition
are duly recognized
we're also be looking to do a formal
Civic opening event at Wallasey Island
to commemorate the installation of the
of the beagle infrastructure subject of
course to risk assessments and Co be
secured so that's something we're also
working on
unfortunately the beagle event that was
due to take place at the freight house
is a little less hmm the event was to be
essentially staffed and managed by a
team of volunteers and contributors from
Darwin and beagle related and scientific
and historic groups from across the
country those volunteers and those
organizations are busy reopening and
looking at their own museums and
institutions so the the plan is to to
make touch base with them in the autumn
to test feasibility of their readiness
to reconstruct our event perhaps in the
summer of next year and as it says in
the report members I would be looking to
make a final decision on that in
November so that a report comes back to
the
this meeting by Christmas at the very
latest and that would be a sort of a go
no-go decision in terms of whether or
not it's feasible to stand out for that
event that's all from me thank you madam
chair
Thank You Angela any questions for
Angela members now okay at paragraph 1.1
on page seven point one of the report
there is one recommendation that's to
note the progress of the ICT migration
project the council led big events
projects planned as part of the discover
2020 and the connect program if no one
misses if no one wishes to move the
recommendation I'm happy to move it from
the chair if I can have a seconder
please
Thank You Daniel okay if we can move on
to the voting please we'll be done on a
roll call of names when Sonia calls out
your name please indicate if you wish to
have the recorded votes and then whether
you're voting for for or against the
recommendation or if you wish to abstain
Thank You members AB to Sonia councilor
FG and no record Evo and for the
recommendation cancer mrs. row no and
for Blues councillor Smith no councillor
Ward for Chancellor Webb no and for
councillor Williams thank you no and for
it cancer watching Thank You members
that motion has been carried unanimously
thank you so we move now swiftly on to
item 8 which is the realignment of the
connect and culture and transformation
program it's a paper from deputy leader
myself and Daniel FD I certainly don't
have anything to add to the report and I
don't think Daniel dust
no thank you sorry counts lefty um dawn
would you like to come in yeah well
report as you say sorry madam chairman
and words make that the recorded for
noting is the realignment of the
connector culture and transformation
program it sets out the change in the
approach for the culture and
transformation program service delivery
and workforce development work streams
the connect program and due to obviously
the changes in the work through the
co-lead but has meant that the workforce
of obviously in moving to agile working
we feel there is an opportunity now to
appoint the transformation program
manager who will be preparing a detailed
project plan which we report you through
the program management office reporting
to the executive where we will be able
to look at the more investor save
projects and this is in line with the
original connect paper that I brought to
February's and committee meeting which
was agreed so I haven't got anything
else to add in lesser than the other
question Thank You dawn
members any questions for dawn okay at
paragraph 1.1 on page eight point one of
the reports there is one recommendation
and that is to note the change in
approach to the connect cultural and
transformation program service delivery
and workforce development every one
person owns the Connect Pro and voting
will take place with as before Thank You
Sonia councilor FG no record votes and
to accept the report no accept the
report please hamster Smith
councillor Ward know and accept the
report
councillor Webb know and to accept the
report
councillor Williams you know and to
accept the report and cancel Wharton
Thank You members that motion has been
carried unanimously
could we please have a recommendation
though to to move this motion I would
prefer not to do it as chairman as I am
named on the paper as its counsel aft so
could we have a moment
move on a motion from somebody else
Thank You councillor Ward and seconder
councillor Arthur Williams thank you
very much that then concludes the
business for this evening members thank
you very much and thank you officers for
your time my closed meeting at 1941
thank you good night